well get ready because our next guest is
one of America's top psychic mediums and
his readings will definitely raise the
hairs on the back of your neck
his noob I hope I'm not too hairy that's
a weird thing to say anyway
his new book when heaven calls comes out
in March and here it is look at all good
applause and he has a new reality show
on E called meet the Frasier's take a
look growing up being psychic was not
easy for me I tried my hardest to push
this ability away but I went to go to
see a medium about a girl that I liked
about all the normal teenage questions
and instead I left hearing that I was a
medium hold on and listening and I
actually had to leave my full-time job
as an EMT because I realized I could use
this ability to help people just in a
different way
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay so wait here's my question cuz like
people watch reality TV and I'm like how
real is reality TV cuz there's cameras
there so that's not real frightening so
listen I uh yes it's both the good and
bad part so I'm on season one so I
didn't know any better than to just act
myself I didn't know I didn't ease keep
doing that don't be weird
yeah I didn't know how much of it would
be on TV whatever I mean they said okay
ignore the cameras just go about your
daily business so you know I went about
my daily business I was on the bidet I'm
getting into my you know my man's space
wait a minute now little did I know that
this was going to end up on TV oh my god
I actually want to be such good friends
with you like the fact that you did that
is I talk about my Spanx all the time
so openly it's so great yeah but I'm a
man Thanks well now I know listen I
didn't know if this faint community
there for men was like was like like
when she was underground
[Laughter]
[Applause]
so we I do have a question though so
you're here so here like are you feeling
anything now yes it's crazy when I look
out into the audience like all I see in
here is dead people like I feel like I'm
connecting it's like the movie $0.06
your that boat is like I feel like I'm
connecting with like the funeral home
because all these souls that are here
you know trying to speak and trying to
connect at first well your mom departed
your mom sitting right next to you can I
get up what what your mother's right
here the way that it works for me is
that when I'm in a room or Amida and in
an area all of your soul so try to come
through and speak and she was just
sitting next to you and saying that's my
daughter that's my daughter so know what
your mom's way of just acknowledging
that you're here and letting you know
that she is okay this was a woman who
had suffered before her passing here in
the physical world because what happens
is Kelly's that they'll put me back in
their body to show me what had going on
and they'll stand next to to show that
they here and she showed me she couldn't
breathe before she had passed she said
on a ventilator
I feel like I'm what like I'm drowning
but I'm going to she had a heart attack
I was in the emergency room she was 62
years old
your mom says to me that first of all
she wants to thank you for keeping a
promise to her she says you promise to
her that you weren't gonna leave her
side because she was afraid she says in
Juneau that my daughter stayed with me
all night long and you laid on the side
of her and you laid with her and your
mom just wants to say thank you so much
for allowing my soul to go the other
side yeah
[Applause]
new details is so creepy and awesome I
am so glad I don't see dead people
though so please dead people if you're
in the room I can't handle it but just
so you know so Matt's new book when
having calls comes out and March here it
is he's calling everybody on this and
don't miss Matt on meet the Frasers
Mondays on e coming up we'll meet a
couple who helped foot the bill for
soldiers trying to get home during the
holiday season please stay with us
[Applause]
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going